une production du studio sf
bio venus sans filtre présentée par
chris miller podcast on parle de
convaincre nos invités date si tu bh
campé avec moins d'hommes blancs gueye
semi vous le savez plan des hardes à
chaque fois qu'ils vendent des produits
sur leur site web en fait qu'ils ont
planté plus de cent mille arbres depuis
2000 20 vivent en planter 69 de plus en
fait dans la prochaine année fait qu'à
chaque fois vous allez vous procurer
quelque chose sur leur site web vous
participez à ce mouvement le et en plus
de ça on a un code promo pour vous qui
le sans filtre 20 assurez-vous de
l'utiliser pour leur montrer que c'est
dieu qui vous envoie puis allez vous
procurer tout sur ces merveilleux qu'est
c'que de cellulaires pour une bonne
cause
donc forcément cette semaine on reçoit
yang avait connu à eau des grans à
l'époque ian qui te qui maintenant un
françois pascal picq ratant le contenu
ou sur les réseaux sociaux que vous
suivez peut-être il fait touche un peu à
tout yann autant au fitness autant qu'au
bien-être
c'est un podcast sur l'iphone os qu'on
s'est ouvert où est-ce qu'on en discute
et nos émotions nos têtes a tendrement
consent ou est condamnée dans nos vies
ce cet espace intéressant puis on a
parlé de son projet de journal s'appelle
montanou
un journal à mi chemin entre le journal
intime qui est un journal de
planification pour atteindre ses
objectifs avec quelque chose qui nous
accompagne au quotidien dans lequel on
conserve le matin on va écrire un peu
nos pensées nos 2 to do list la journée
et quitter le terrain il fait tout
lui-même du cover à l'intérieur puis on
retrouve air max un projet spa
intéressant qui ont volé l'antiquité
avec lui chaque pour ce qu'on a reçu
comme valu d'être c'est vraiment super
hier juste avant d'aller écouter notre
version avec yann on va aller remercier
nos communes stone le podcast
aujourd'hui est présenté par studio sf
le lieu dans lequel on se boivent
présentement le csf vous pouvez le louer
pour réaliser vos projets des créations
vidéos de podcasts
d'enregistrement vocal de toutes sortes
livres audio des livres audio peut venir
ici et on va vous accompagner dans la
création de votre contenu et en suisse
ce taux est en train de passer à l'oni
voulons ni des ménages à toulouse au
niveau local comme pouvoir y voit
plusieurs set up plusieurs locaux on va
en voir c'est un endroit pour tirer pour
être cosy pour un bien pour recevoir les
invités fassent ici que ça se passe fort
création de tout contenu enchantement
par quatre le nombre de colons font
n'est aussi des yes que vous n'avez même
pas besoin de vous soucier d'aucun point
technique partition dans notre équipe de
techniciennes et techniciens qui vont
s'occuper de vous qui vont vous vous
prendre dans ce 3g l'oeil s'assurer que
tout soit comme vous le voulez vous
n'avez qu'a vous concentrer sur la
création de votre contenu qui est on
s'occupe de tout le reste est calée au
studio sfr ainsi à pour avoir plus
d'informations sur ce point
le podcast de cette semaine est aussi
présentée par notre page piquionne sur
laquelle en ce moment où dans les
prochains jours en fait va se retrouver
plusieurs podcast pré enregistrée en
début de semaine ont fait ça maintenant
on essaie de de faire des petits blast
d'enregistrement pour pouvoir se libérer
un petit peu dans nos dans nos vies
respectives
il va avoir sur le sur le pétrole dans
les prochains jours je vais avoir le
podcast avec kenza avec
en quatre journées avec
toulouse une circulaire devrait vivre
avec bourjois je devais un jour c'est
pas déjà là ça va être le départ bon pas
de casque on a enregistré dans un petit
blitz qui vous serez pas déçus puis sous
une bâche courage et si sophie john que
ça soit ça fait vraiment une grande
différence quelques dollars par mois un
autre me permirent du consul par les
podcasts il est toujours s'améliorer et
de mettre la mort toujours pluie qui s
est qualifiée ketchup merci merci m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le cerf-volant passante j'ai jamais
compris plus jamais vraiment écouter ça
mais jamais compris non plus l'intérêt
ouais c'est assez relax ah ben ouais
mais moi j'ai commencé à faire du à
écouter
et appelle ce jeudi bausch kraft fait
déjà ses genres dans la nature vexé
mettons un gars qui s'envoient trois
jours dans une forêt à -30 mais qui
survivent puis messi c'est la vidéo
s'est récemment fait que ces gens
tentant
l'église construit un abri complet
entendre les cris tenants du feu
genre fonte de la neige pour se faire un
tête à
queue mais tu vois ce c'est quand même
relaxant mais des bruits de bouche
annoncé c'est autre chose aucunement
wahou capable émettant toi toi quelqu'un
qui mange
gens qui marchent pas je dis ça prend
pas de terrain qui je te reprends où je
sors de la table or voilà
faut quand même soit maintenant c'est
par ses fonctions à proximité que la
personne pour idir hyman manager
absolument un métier mais aussi
les critiques mais pas je vais peut être
regarder l'autre personne que ça fait là
méritent autant pique nique toi là
dessus
mais pauvre et jeudi mettant quelques
uns qui fréquentent
la cuisine
la mamie mais ce
jour-là ce genre d'affaires luc sont un
peu p dit le jdd genre de trucs qui sont
au final pas si important mais quand
même assez pour fiat dérange plus il ya
comme un ratio le faisait plus date un
amour naissant dans le monde et c'est
trop tard le secam que ça fait six mois
qu'on se rend compte qu'une seule j'ai
un peu changé ma façon de boire de l'eau
à cause ma première parce que je faisais
vraiment
mais ouais mais c'est mieux qu'avant qu
est-ce qu avec une pole mais efficace
mais pourquoi tu buvais de l'eau tu sais
tu aspires l'eau
j'espérais juste de sang l'avers pauget
je fais une succession de leur cavale de
sept pour cent des problèmes de garde
non élucidées mais problème de garde
aussi
comment style
du fait que j'aimerais me go way
marrant mais jeudi était le problème
bref c'est le début de parcs as le plus
ouvrir de son corps entre vos mains ça
va bien ça va vraiment content et si yes
on s'était jamais vu non puis on s'est
vus la semaine passée
barbecue des filles
rapidement melody par les 30 secondes tu
as dit à norma moyenne et les réseaux
sociaux je suis capable georges pas bon
train
[Musique]
avec toi toi dans le fond la vendée le
terrain tu tu avais une présence et
médias sociaux tels de thuir actifs pape
entre jeunes avaient une liste est
quasiment 100% destiné à ma business ou
si dans ce temps là j'étais vraiment
entre autonome en train priver puisque
la seule utilité je trouve assez c'est
pour me trouver des clients pour un
parent pis en allant au disque est ce la
première
la première motivation c'est quand même
un
job faire ce que je faisais avant après
mais éventuellement un jour je dis ça se
passe pas comme cela va se passer mais
c'est tellement de choses par après
celle ci aussi mais à la base c'était
comme ok parfait un outil
magique pour justement faire connaître
ton produit ou ce que tu as envie
d'offrir aux gentils et puis je pense
que essentiellement c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une bonne c'est vraiment un bel
outil c'est juste certains points
quantiques comment sa troupe consomme
ips à nier ta job samedi s'il faut
trouver le juste milieu puisque pour ce
qu'il ya souvent des tilal est passé
durant l'été je faisais des 24 heures
des 48 heures de face de réseaux sociaux
jeux comme
appris qu'après 24 heures j'ai commencé
à leur dire d'arrêter là on le mange des
carmes qui j'ai arrêté je fermais mon -
instagram j'avais juste mes textos pour
mes parents mes amis crocheter mais pas
de réseaux sociaux pas de consommation
de médias sociaux t puis après 24 heures
je voyais un chiffre haut niveau ce que
je pensais mais ils misent dé tout jeter
comme ok ben c'est tellement un autre
aspect
non jeu quand je dis ceci c'est
tellement vide pas évident mais je veux
dire c'est une réalité mais de la vraie
vie aussi nourri de jeu j'ai commencé
justement beaucoup plus méditer pour
faire des choses comme ça les idées ont
quadrillé juste à faire sauter en
faisant arrêter de me comparer parce que
tu regardes - réseaux sociaux évidemment
dit qu on part moins pendant ça c'est
tout ce jeu
t'apprendre connaître de plus en plus ce
que tu aimes ce que tu aimes pas qui tu
veux devenir hétéro et fax et des
questions que je finissais ma part me
poser juste en prenant un step back à
travers mes 24 heures 48 ans est un
petit challenge enfin bon jeu juste qui
mentionne encore le lendemain que ça me
rajoute comme une mule plus à penser à
ce que c'est
parce que ça amène des fois ça paraît
que cinq minutes ça va donner ce procédé
sur facebook c'est et c'est ces essais
du tarn ain pige qu'on se dit
c'est un peu vide dans le sens que nous
faut c'est fermé 6 pi la vie et continue
et il a envoyé
un missile à les guérir la caverne mais
qu'on apprend le haut cgt puis de comme
l'image était avec les ombres qui sont
projetés plus le monde les prisonniers
sont obligés de regarder plutôt comme le
frein arrière piloté et comme une
description que jacques nuoffer métier
c'est l'allégorie de la caverne c'est
quand tu sors des cavernes petit film
finalement tu vois la lumière du soleil
lot et tu vois la vérité non en tueuse
dans cavernes je pense la caverne c'est
le monde
voici ce que je pense que c'est tout
lorsque le mime c'est comme les ombres
c'est comme genre d et pignons vraiment
tranché puis vraiment une scène sur
internet c'est comme ça la caverne ses
marques et genre de guerre ou laghdaf le
geek il a gardé des réseaux sociaux ses
marques littéralement
sortir de ces tellement c'était la
vérité jeudi avec l'ani qu'on a eue de
pandémie de d'isolation des plus voir
tout est restreint tout le monde se
retourne vers
guy et le nom de manifestations puis de
cosco dernières années je faisais ne
peut pas fonctionner bien mentalement
tout au long de l'année en ayant tout le
temps et une nouvelle nouvelle nouvelle
le jeu 10 mois pourrait vous êtes bon de
regarder tout à l'actualité puis on a
décroché un autre fils
j'ai vraiment ralentir la vague une
période que c'était au début ce
confinement c'était ont selon les têtes
brûlées c'était tout le temps vous tout
savoir tout suivre
et des fois tu étais même pas au courant
des brûlés après connectique of sarnath
mis un petit peu de moi mais ça te prend
des paramètres pour le forcer à
décrocher t elle avec la dernière année
je demande les poignées ou tu peux pas
moins de force qui conditionne à face et
comme j'ai fait tellement j'ai fait
comme un stan ici ça va être une
expérimentation n'importe quoi que je
pense bull d'essayer comme ça je peux en
parler jugé après et puis où on voit
comment moi je
poserai en personne ce que je fais pour
moi je dis je le partage puis si ça fit
à vous ben faut l'essayer puis si l'on
me dise pas plus grave que ça mais pour
ce qui est du genre avant de parler des
sujets et je met dedans je souhaitais
depuis juin puis on voit que ça dans le
temps
mais wes qui aimait tant ton plat des
vies saas étudier moi je voulais vous
allez vous dire je construis une phase
que je faisais continue de fermer
dimitru des trainings date 7 pi ou est
pourquoi que ça des vignerons de
[Musique]
force parce que tu peux vraiment autant
que tu peux avoir une idée ça va être
cool à appréhender c'est pas cher un
tulle vie et j'ai vu que si je
commençais à faire vraiment plus de
choses ma présence en ligne côté tuning
côté programme en ligne aussi déjà et
j'ai même plus besoin de déplacer
techniquement avec le
one si on veut que je me déplace en
hidjab ce genre s'était rendu sans
perdre de temps il dans le trafic pips
cette magie ça commencé à dévier
tranquillement comme tout ce que non
mais le sais parce que j'étais rendue si
bizarre à dire mais je te rendre parano
de mélie clients qui vont venir me voir
pour me josée d'audi ou pour vraiment
s'entraîner puis ça me tentait même pas
d'essayer trancher entre ce que j'ai
fait comme elle je prends plus personne
je me suis mis au pied du mur je suis
personne je veux rien arranger en ligne
propos de comment ça va se passer la
carapace de plus ces jeux 10 rebonds et
avec un compte instagram comme mesurer
les collabos qui arrive qui fait avec un
peu ton life starts to fuck sasac
savanes en balance pitt devient plus
créative plus artistique au fil des
années que j'en suis le chemin la manche
plus artiste que je pensais puis à
prendre exactement mais quand je te dise
et de step back harper de mettre sur ton
écran touche comme lui j'en ai dix des
faux je suis venu prendre le temps de
les évaluer et noter
mais vraiment là vous deviez dû placer
si positif absolument absolument positif
puis se passe la france et qui
je peux
je sais pas si je conditionné comme ça
mais je vois jamais me laisser aller
ouais
moi je peux dire une spirale négative
berrah négative ça va être négatif
jusqu'à temps mais je m'en sorte et puis
je trouve quelque chose d'autre puis je
m'accroche à des projets qui me tiennent
à coeur que j'aime dit honnêtement le
monde qui me regarde et il voit dans le
projet du temps j'aurai quelque chose de
différent mais ça reste dans la même
histoire de bien en été mais si ce que
j'aime si je suis sème des graines un
peu partout puis après ce bain tout ce
que j'ai offensés à les récolter pis
pour ceux qui l'utilisent j'ai juste
avec un projet que j'aime le mais j'en
ai un autre le jeu ne le jetez pas
nécessairement obligé de te confiné à un
projet je pense pas avoir plus en fait
tout le monde plusieurs fois l'intérêt
et puis c'est juste je pense et je sors
plus de pouvoir les développer tout
suspense train de luxe ou s'il fait que
ça
t2 par son entraîneur à
plus entrepreneur artistique je suis
encore là demain jeudi il n'y a pas
nécessairement besoin d'étiquette
métier la question qui me suit en ce
moment le service
pouvait rien ou plein de choses j'ai
aucune idée une entreprise d'un bon
chapeau 3 mai tombent dans les
boxes et entrepreneurs exercent
à quai mais qu'est ce que tu entreprends
levante a billion instagram le tient
vraiment
fan de résidents
tu disais tantôt
ça m'a marqué parce que j'ai cette
conversation a dernièrement
que quand tu te retires des réseaux
sociaux tu es capable de réévaluer c'est
quoi tes ruff parce que aussi côté
objectifs mais ton parce que quatre
écoles et dessus me changer et et
jean jé subissent ils d'être collé sur
sur instagram le devoir qui est quand
même et on qui est en ce moment en ce
moment que le confinement est rompu le
fait que
la mariage que les pas tant de monde que
ça j'ai pas tué deux groupes d'amis
mettons qui vont à lecce dans un parc en
sorte que le jeu sur instagram le jouage
comme crayssac et les eau sont sur une
terrasse s'ils ont l'air de tripes et
lacs et les autres sont dans un parc
mardi ont l'art de tromper les crises
moi aussi la seconde qui je dépanne on
se lave que je me pose je suis honnête
envers moi même je me dis
mardi soir mais ne devrait pas sûr être
le sait ses potes c'est pas 2 sata parti
un poste c'est juste un rêve que tu vois
seulement que tu dis est que parce que
tu le vois tu penses que c'est ce que tu
veux tu mets que la seconde que tu
arrêtes des textes proposés à ceux
où hôtel logis sûr mais ça peut être
quelqu'un qu'il faut qu'un succès dans
quelque chose qui m'intéresse pas
pantoute la saison que tu arrêtes exposé
a satisfait crise finale mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas moi ch'ti sa part rapport
le tir sauf que si tu es là d'entrer
dans une spirale diverses et moi c'est
moi c'est moi je veux faire sur le faire
sur le pommeau et s'imaginer comment je
suis un fil conducteur qui n'est pas
seulement il nécessairement le tir en
faisant pour sa manie de travail tu
feras paris caen et cela dit je veux
vivre s'est comparé à des gens qui eux
mêmes pas bien leur vie barque
non mais c'est vrai ce samedi bon point
parce que quand s'est dit confiant et
j'ai eu une angoisse là l'ambiance au
stade rennes de ce qui se passe chez
nous même en train de gens me coucher de
bonne heure pour pour travailler demain
genre alors que tout le monde devrait
trice d'apple c'est juste c'est pas ta
vie mais
c'est pas pour toi même si des fois t'es
comme tu es juste besoin de te faire
inviter pour savoir qui est invitée mais
ce n'était pas envie d'y croire puisque
j'étais point que sa tante polly
merci une invitation mais je dois
prendre soin mollo
force de faire c'est de renforcer des
conditions des amis après je l'avais
tribu bien pu la vraie toujours laissé
mes chutes je prends ton point j'ai vécu
la même chose quand je conseille tout le
monde chez redmond belleville est
toujours la plus hot wheels et les
influenceurs mettons voyage est sa vie
ses voyages et prendre des photos
partout à travers le monde s'arrête
incroyable mais ja oui ça va quand même
être cool mais ça n'a pas de couilles
100% de sts à ce titre les agro porte
tout était tout les côtés mais
logistique tu cites a sûrement des gens
c'est la photo l'image est incroyable je
dois y ait toute l'ariège qui pousse
tout le temps sinon est-ce que ce
et la soirée au parc s'il est petit
extrait que tu voyais tout le monde de
la mode iphone des smartphones ce soir
et le munster était c'était pas la
soirée d'une ville et à la plus naïve
les buts que tu vois que tout ce qui
autorise derrière toutes les stories de
l'historie à quelqu'un comme ce qui se
fait dans une soirée entre amis derrière
chacune historique et eric essentielle
dans un milieu social alors que tout le
monde fait qu est pourquoi se sont ils
passés camier gagner puis toutes les
stars il est souvent plus beaux moments
plus belles soirées mettons que j
jugez les petites réflexions déjà crise
gpo fait historique parce que j'étais
vraiment hot mettons ce qui se passait
un petit je me disais que je n'ai pas
fait par le moment de raison de lever de
fonds
mais si fou de justement avoir le
réflexe maintenant franchement j'en ai
pas fait j'ai vécu quelque chose
d'amusant les professeurs
visite pour ce camani quand ça vraiment
décroche étaient comme
m côté pour de vrai et puis danger' amal
mamans présentes et puis souvent
tellement que je dis ils vont te lis
dans leur tête et je veux montrer que je
tiens aussi à la clé ils font une
histoire humaine en font leur première
motivation c'est juste d'un patrimoine
pas nécessairement des clubs m'ont dit
qu'ils sont il pas temps
on s'aperçoit rejoint par cofely désole
quand ils seront d'accord on va se
coucher dehors
[Rires]
mais nani ont parlé des influenceurs qui
voyagent partout mais on compare notre
vie mais ton on est ici à montréal en ce
moment qui leur a est l'hôte est depuis
six mois est parti à et les parties
influentes partie les paramètres de vie
jeudi et responsabilités c'est peut-être
pas les mêmes non plus tout emprunt 2
est en train de bâtir un empire avec
qu'est ce que vous faites en ce moment a
dit non mais c'est vrai et au galaxy
mais
je vous dis
je mais ce grand or si vous êtes dedans
tout le temps puis ça reste dans le
temps je peux dire qui a été tu peux
aller passer six mois en plus de
posséder des choses puisque roddick ça
reste dans le temps un serment tc a
recommencé à chaque fois la photo de
dieu est plus grand car face au no c'est
tout un ton podcast dédié à la 2 du mois
dernier on a parlé tantôt de velotte
deux ans il se faire écouter encore et
encore si ça reste dans le temps puis je
pense que ce ça mérite de vraiment plus
exploitée moi je pense qu'il
exige comme on sait depuis je pense
vraiment ce que je vous envie de dire ça
en fait partie d'un des motivations cédé
entre un impact c'est sûr c'est sûr que
d'avoir l'impression mettons comprend le
podcast comme exemple avant l'impression
d' amener quelque chose à quelqu'un
c'est vraiment le fun c'est comme le
monde qui chaque fois qu'on reçoit un
message
petit
j'écoutais ça c'est vraiment ça va
vraiment fait réfléchir à telle affaire
où j'aimerais le souhaiter
ça c'est une plus grande gratification
que mettons au début quand j'étais plus
actif sur instagram pour des collabos
aussi des influenceurs en guinée quand
j'essayais de le faire
c'était vide complètement l'at-il leur
tour que j'avais cédé rails mais c'était
pas changer pour changer la vie de
personnes seulement fait que pilote
comme sans dire qu'on change la vie des
gens mais comme on fait partie de leur
quotidien
y a plus de profondeur aussi comme
feedback exact quelque chose qu'au final
on est fiers si on fait quelque chose
que c'est peut-être que s'il y avait
trop personnes qui nous écoutent est tel
qu'on le ferait pas mais je dire on le
dit fort à faire si c'est un projet
qu'on connait fiard pic on retrouve t on
monterait de sujets qu'ils considéraient
importantissime plus humblement mais
genre que ce soit un succès c'est
gratifiant pas ce que tu dis qu'il est
l'heure le projet auquel je crois que je
trouve un portable que je trouve que je
trouve nice bailly réseau l'adisq et si
j'ai pas le temps
quelque chose qui me touche c'est pour
le genre une photo
mettant quelque chose que je mettrais
que je sortirai mais je me disais pas
associer vraiment hamas mais mais je dis
qu'est ce ça va marcher mais tout un
peuple a donc mais je sais que ça va
marcher quand ça marche c'est moins de
latitude
c'est vraiment
quelque chose que tu mets un petit trip
sa table tu décides de te faire un
projet qu'elle croit vraiment à toi qui
peux toi qui essaient des calculs et
qu'est ce que le monde veut l'entendre
qu'est-ce que monde veulent voir ce qui
est requis moi je suis ce moi je fais ça
tu le store opéra plus sur mon âme ce
qu'est ce que je ferai pour toi est ce
que tu t'es coûterait par les gens
parlent d'une conversation à ce que tu
l'écouterai wii qui est parfait si c'est
dans cette direction là que vous allez
c'est je pense que j'ai été souvent je
demande à ces réflexions l'heure de jeu
par jeu par plusieurs projets pour tous
mais à chaque fois je me dis eh qu'est
ce que moi je suis liseret ok c'est ce
que je lui j'en équipe comme moi je
l'utiliserai tu pour moi est ce que je
règle besoin est ce que c'est oui je
comme un parfait parce qu'après je me
fous complètement d'opinion des gens
parce que je fais quelque chose qui est
bien moins est ce que je me suis libérée
lorsque je m'auto suivre
métis
c'est absolument ses appuis je dis tu
peux te plantes en cours de route mais
au final tu essaies déguiser un peu plus
ton chemin vers quelque chose que c'est
100% touati puis dernièrement j'ai
partie des planches des notebooks jeudi
je fais du jogging puis je dire un gars
partir des planeurs des tordus des
journaux c'est comme
le 2 ans tu m'avais dit si j'avais fait
mais j'aurais pas cru nécessairement ce
qui au final même ça marche pas comme je
l'aï fait pour moi je
voulais parfait il y en a mais à la base
je le fais pour moi puis c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui avec elle je crois
puis ce pauvre et la gratification j'ai
même si en revanche sur un jeu comme le
feeling dans vos pass à travers de
processus de création de la banque mais
me décris dans mon
comme sensing puissions adapter mon plus
beau projet si on veut de
gratification vu comme ceux dits de
fierté si on veut qui aboutit à quelque
chose pour moi c'est vraiment adapter
ses outils surtout du john hocking tu
faisais ça ça fait longtemps que ce gie
toujours en fait je pense tout le monde
pense trop d'envié aussi mais j'ai quand
même des fois moi je tombe en ruine à
trop de tâches pis le genre ce que je
fais plus rien le chien le cheveu impies
le satan
comme amy spirale négative les commencé
tout temps quand il ya trop de choses
trop procrastination puis éventuellement
si ça fait deux ans qu'on s'ajuste des
bouts de papier noter tout ce qui me
empêche comme ok sur ça se prépare ça
fait dix ans que j'en suis sorti de ma
tête c'est l'état joue un peu de
l'écriture automatique de n'importe quoi
que ce soit du goût de sortir de toile
ça a commencé avec des torches que
éventuellement c'est ce que j'ai fait
exactement exactement c'était vous savez
par rapport avec comment je me sens
quoique ce soit et je te comme bleach
c'était vraiment suscité dans le temps
ces jeux quand je faisais
je m'étais maintenant maggie
ratification je la trouvais dans comment
j'étais productif aujourd'hui tient
maintenant ça complètement j'ai trouvé
l'équilibré entre les deux c'est
vraiment ouais c'est beau être productif
mais je dis ta journée c'est une
pratique si ça veut pas dire qu'ils
aient repris son histoire qui était pote
tu es vraiment pas dans le bien être
pour le thé vraiment jong est celle
d'une ville et gounod c'est drôle je
sais cours parenthèses - il veut
convaincre sur ce sujet là parce que ça
m'intéresse beaucoup le mais c'est
justement moins une journée productive
pour moi ça inclut mettons avoir pris
soin de m'avoir fait ch permettant le
cas remettant ses cages déjà été
productif aujourd'hui je vois jamais
dire ceux ci j'ai juste travailler si on
est des journées où est ce qu'on vient
ici on fait trois pas de casque on est
quand même de dante la journée j'arrive
chez nous ou brûlés je suis du genre 6
hors piste un peu amorphe puis je fais
rien moi j'étais 0 productive cette
journée là même si j'ai fait beaucoup
d'efforts mais comme un matin je me suis
levé challenge m l'on vient faire deux
podcasts et puis on va rentrer puis le
chauffard
d'ailleurs la journée où la balle en jg
pas très long j'aime bien mais j'ai pas
mangé de croire que j'ai petit je jouais
arriver chez nous la fois aux mêmes
productif à 100% alors que c'est au
niveau de la job pas une des journées
les plus productives qu'on a eu on a eu
des produits ciblent que ça sauf qu'un
arrimage chinois soient
extrêmes
devraient sûrement changer le mot
productif pour jean équilibristes la
belle journée sa journée équilibrée
exactement ce qu'est ce que tu as fait
du sport tous y travailler à des projets
et avancé des enfants de gens ramènent
tout de même fait une sieste qui stephen
king productif en guinée équilibré dans
le fond tout a bien marché et a fait
toute sa flotte dormi a cessé comme en
fait foi manifeste montgueux pour
changer le mot parent c'est vrai que
j'aimerais c'est vrai que c'est là on
devrait maintenant de vrais gens de
poursuivre le fait d'avoir dit des
journées équilibré tous les journées
productif mais c'est un peu le message
que je
[Rires]
sais c'est un peu le message que je
pense de plus en plus t'es avant c'était
quand je faisais avant on dit mettons
quand je traîne instaurant en plus axée
sur physique puis plus à l'avance plus
tu es jeux j'allais vers l'intérieur
c'était vraiment plus le mettons tout
senti bien oui parfait mais par des food
force physique ça va paraître
propose des packs mais jusqu'à
maintenant t'as pas d'ici pâques on s'en
cogne je n'ai rien à faire qu'on qui fit
plus t'avances tout est comme s est
vraiment pour ce qui est important c'est
puis c'est fou de mots mais ton ancien
mois bleu comme 4 5 ans ma tite comment
ce n'est pas aussi jeudi et évolue de
ton fils conducteurs qui m'offre je peux
pas croire parce que mentalement c'était
c'était comme sur le stand up and down
s'était dit montagnes russes petit à
petit à chaque année ce ne sera pas pour
ce que je me trouve des outils puis le
chant reine de crime et outils que moi
me sorte je peux partager aux gens qui
peut s'appuyer les aider et puis
justement bonne journée plus équilibré
je pense qu'un espace de 50 à 3
c'est vraiment ce le but jusqu'à
maintenant je me sens vraiment mis pour
de vrai puisque et de la journée que je
manque il faut montrer ni quoi que ce
soit je mange en fait point que j'en
fais pas un drame si j'ai fait d'autres
choses genre de notre façon j'ai pris
soin de moi puis stoppée c'est un peu à
ce jeu-là revenue c'est comme ça ça de 8
minder acquis et esprit ça aujourd'hui
non peu importe comme se disait ça peut
être une sieste c'est la sieste pauvres
et si tu regardes long terme tu veux des
journées team et ont claqué six podcast
par jour on s'entend que sais tu peux
pas faire sur une semaine un mois ou un
an parfois deux trois puis
exactement entier mais si tu regarde à
long terme qui est commun dans 20 ans je
veux pouvoir continuer en santé en plus
puis performer dans mon travail ça te
prend toutes ces éléments dans mes
journées répéter aux 420 x factor c'est
un peu comme ma mentalité depuis depuis
deux trois ans environ que j'ai c'est de
vraiment petit comme tu dis ouf il a
apprécié cette journée stands rainbow
août pas eu l' équilibre parfait manet
seront plus pas grave si après ce tas
semaine et équilibrées m après ce ton
mot et équilibre et c'est après ce genre
d'avis d'équilibrer le facteur fait que
c'est sûrement ce genre à chaque jour ma
presse aussi dans les dents les
maquereaux dans le maquereau qui est
cyclique et équilibrée que c'est des
fois on regarde tellement injuste l'a
toujours nine vieille c'est tellement de
journée demande fillon ne pas finir une
chose mais faisait de la journée que tu
as besoin pour te reposer pour faire les
trois prochaines comme semences et il
prend une cire syrien de jeudi ne faut
pas de sens mal le genre 20 minutes par
un homme jeudi que ça fait des miracles
cesser ses mains se passe la vie je
tombais dans autre chose mais ce parce
que la vie est tellement longue c'est
tellement fois king long c'est vraiment
la différence l'antre
entre je faisais du président natation
plus je m'entraîne vraiment plus en
endurance gens pour des marathons c'est
vraiment la différence entre les deux
c'est ton sprint l'êtes pas le temps de
passer par un million d'émotion le téton
sprint quatre quant aux mâles normales
c'est fini tu es mai - tu arrives au mur
c'est dati dans ton marathon en es tu
peux avoir une chute d'énergie je peux
revenir après ça tu peux avoir un bon
moment une passe plus plus plus tough
mais si je veux dire
s'écouter en un an c'est quoi le mettons
un an le camp convois circulent élèves
qu'on va regarder notre vie au complet
dans l'ensemble l'outil 11 pas d'une
année mme et on voit ce que le
camp thé dansant la leyre da et infiniti
et mettons la cofidis est le meilleur
exemple lakovic a duré un an et demi le
mettons que ça dure encore mais mettons
lahoud est confirmée donc on dit à un an
et demi de com de calvaire quand tu es
dedans comme qui risque cette année
georges plus capables si la seule
affaire que tu vois mais quand on
circule et là on va regarder semaine on
va avoir tellement plus de moments où
est-ce qu'on n'est pas dans qu'ovide
fake cité cavare de textures paix de
type de regarder le dira mais ça c'était
une année de merde premièrement quand et
dash est ce que je capable c'est quoi de
mieux que je peux faire avec la
situation car c'est quand leur culture
c'est de sortir du fénoir mais
finalement c'était pas absolument pas si
brillant dans l'échelle de la grosse
affaire je pense qu'au final au tenté
comme aux jours maintenant d'études et
ça peut sembler négatif dans la petite
aurait tout recul de tupi je pense pas
que on veut tout savoir développer
quelque chose en soi avec cette année le
samedi à fort minique export on s'est
peut-être peut-être le moment je n'ai
peut-être pas tout le monde qui est au
courant de ce qu'ils ont accompli son
nom contient mais jeudi en disant
regardez à atton années 2020 2021 soit
cap où j'ai grandi dans cette année le
jeudi tout le monde comme ça le
challenge pour tout le monde peut
importer la zone de thé ou dans vie je
dis que tu as de l'argent on peut tout
le monde un certain point en ne soit et
je pense juste que comme tu dis mais moi
je trouve qu'il est le monde soit un peu
impatient si c'est comme en finale kévin
c'est après six mois c'est comme acquis
mais je comprends mais en même temps
justement comme si je sais quoi dans une
vie tiges des gens comme étant j'ai pas
envie de rentrer là dedans le même sens
en australie le lion fermés ceux qui ont
ce qu'est leur pendant un an de son
groupe et jeudi mais on dirait que c'est
la passion de voir un peu plus loin qui
est juste le bout de notre nez
c'est ce qui m'étonne dans dix ans je
pense qu'à ce moment qui vous regardez
en ce moment il faut se sosa a été de la
mab training point de ma vie j'ai changé
sociaux puis maintenant qui va la faire
crever c'est sûr que beaucoup manquent
pas dire celui est trop tôt pour le dire
mais tu es maintenant leur celui-ci
genre max pas max parole si kim kim des
meilleurs au monde en snowboard type
c'est comme lui même pendant qu'il y
avait le cancer le sait la marle gens
réfléchis et on souhaite sa personne qui
genre c'est cnc world mais il se dit
dans le micro de mtv
si j'avais le choix j'offre georges je
leur ferais même enfin jean jacques
anceau choisir je choisirais
autant que ça a été
la pire épreuve de sa vie tipi un
complément horrible d'un genre ça
complètement changé la manière dont il
voyait la vie dont il voyait le monde
autour de lui dont il donc ça tout le
temps de fondre sur l'échelle des
valeurs tout a changé depuis aujourd'hui
reconnaît qu' crise ma meilleure
personne qui crissement plus + wise
crissement plus à cause de soucis mais
50 et dans six candidats sur le boul
j'avais oublié ça mais ces bébés de
penser se débine mais la chaîne a choisi
c'est une donne l'option genre choisi le
mauvais temps qu'il le peut juste et
humaine choisi de ne pas la barre
mais ça c'est un bon point mais je sais
pas pour vous mais des fois je me met
dans des situations dans ma tâche comme
et je veux juste en soi commanderie je
suis comme motivé par avoir le plus
d'expérience possible peu importe de co2
négatifs possibles ces deux expériences
de jeu comme j je le souhaite pas
toucher du bois comme je dire
jamais eu un deuil à faire d'une
personne proche où justement une maladie
ou quelque chose comme j 10 épreuves
comme comment ça serait quoi ma vie
ayant vécu ce type ge com je me pose la
question parce que éventuellement c'est
sûr qu'on veut tous deux projetés c'est
la vie mais je comme des fois je me mets
dans des positions mental comme ça je
crois comme ça me ramène le plus autant
j'aurais comme ça me ferait vraiment
pire où j'essaye vraiment de pousser ce
lointain c'est possible effet des
l'imaginer sans rien à voir avec le
vivre mais non au moins tu essaies de te
fait d'être mettre en mode
empathie ou en mode s'y essayer de
comprendre ce que ce mythe est
déjà si je te disais donc si tu meurs
demain
serait pas la même façon ils étaient
juste des
saturdays pour la question c'est quoi
qui est vraiment important c'est que
j'ai vraiment peur à toutes ces
questions et qui vit qui viennent le
fait que je pense qu'elle amorce une
grosse motivation se peut la tournée
at-on certain avantage de plus juste te
mettre dans ce scénario la nantaise
comme une sorte de motivation 100% mois
ce qui est simple film et ont pensé à se
dire maintenant est ce que si je meurs
demain
faudrait que je me pose cette question
le plus souvent parce que quand je pose
cette question l'a dit est ce que
maintenant ce que j'ai fait à ces mets
ton pour être pour dire à date j'ai fait
mon travail maintenant j'ai juste à
servir à quelque chose que je pense site
le matin puis quand tu pas cette
question-là cernant perspectives aussi
certaines affaires que tu fais que te
dire de la questure dans le fossé ça
participe pas à mon mythe personnel
c'est ça passait pas
mon histoire que j'aime écrire le
terrain tant la sq est en train de faire
le puits quand tu poses la question pour
de vrai c'est
étonnant être avec toi même tu réalises
que certaines pizzas fort puis moi
dernières années j'ai quand même c'est
monaco vit ce jeu là c'était pour pour
reprendre l'exemple de max lacave et je
les reprendrai le sait mais dont l'année
ennemis qu'on vient de passer le jeu
leur prendrait même si par bouddha et
étoffe des fois je te jeter j'étais pas
bien des fois j'avais envie dès que ça
finisse au plus vite des fois je
m'ennuyais de the tourist peu quitte en
colère mais je le reprendrais parce que
j'y reviens en place beaucoup ça parle
que je me suis dans le film king de dire
excuse est en train de faire
vraiment
ce qui va bénéficier à mon histoire afin
qu'ils puissent la réponse de nos
cheveux puis la dent dans la dernière
année cette question là qui revenue de
com de décider de me situer dans mes
objectifs mes rêves mais mes but qui est
comme arriver ça le fait un espèce de la
dernière défaite en espèces de ménage en
fait dans tout ce je pense qu'ils ont
nié toutes les sphères de ta vie mais
ton mettons le jeu pose des questions
comme qu'est ce qui était le plus
déterminant avec la preuve la dernière
en ayant qu'est-ce qu'elle changeait
qu'est ce qui a changé du tout au tout
les versets 2019-2020 mettons dont
l'année de pandémie qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qu'elle peut changer une deux bords
moi j'ai réalisé puis c'est la chose
principale pour moi j'ai réalisé que
fallait
que je que ma vie soit complétée à
l'intérim avis mais je demande mon ton
bien à mon bien-être puis ma direction
pima stabilité pauvre financière ni de
lieu mais émotionnel nathan soit
complète avant que n'importe qui d'autre
plus y entrer ou jouer dans ce lot
mettons cela il fallait que moi je sois
pauvre finale parce que je veux jamais
finale du béton mais je voulais être une
version je voulais être beaucoup plus
établie maintenant avoir les deux pieds
staff roquettes date c'est ça c'est mon
c'est ma vie c'est ce que j'aime ça
c'est mes but puis l'acquis et l'on peut
parler si quelqu'un veut venir dans ce
par défaut ça fait le ménage de ton
entourage tous âges dans ta vie qui tu
veux pas te remet tout en question puis
c'est fou parce que je pense par le même
processus ceci pis
pour toi mais je dirais je pense qu' on
a tous fait en plus le processus de
faillite
et je dirais plus de sorties et puis le
réseau est plus faux col il ya du monde
que tu voyages juste part
c'est con veniant 6-1 au resto mais
stadium de resto au final ils vous
parlez de quoi elle les a pas vus
pendant un an et demi j'en ai pas rendu
compte
que ça a vraiment ça restreint le cirque
social vraiment mais le monde qui sont
restés finalement c'était tellement d
essentielle tient la corde essentiel de
la vie
vraiment vraiment moss y avait plein de
monde que je voyais tout le temps tout
le temps du temps toutes les semaines
dans des bars des événements d'affaires
pendant qu'elle savoure ouvrir les
revoir leur content de revoir mais tu es
dans le fond ce dépôt ce n'est pas mon
cercle rapproché de monde que j'ai
vraiment besoin d'eux qu'ils montrent
que je vais appeler quelques jeter
quelques j'ai besoin de parler ou qui
souhaitent se fatiguer c'est ce mois ça
a été vraiment
fait des plus professionnelles le
changement des mots mettons je suis
musicien david puis
j'ai commencé mes études en musique en
2008 au cégep partir de ce moment là ça
a été
à fond de train ça a été
ça marche il faut que je travaille
quatre fort qu importe qu'ils n'étaient
faxer genre que la pratique qui est de
l'instrument que ce soit juste comme les
projets où que ce soit gravé son chèque
c'était comme à fond à fond à fond tout
le temps requis mendy j'étais à fond par
l'argent pendant 11 ans 12
jusqu'à ce que la pandémie arrive piqué
le georges face
pour la première fois arrêté pendant des
mots comme en repos forcé au repos forcé
pire recul forcé aussi puis
c'était une bonne affaire pascal en et
tiges je travaillais beaucoup dans ce
milieu là puis ça laisse pas bien mais
genre s'était pas exactement ce que je
le fais plus justement la pandémie
tomber comme tout arrêter plus j'ai pu
comme juste redirige rediriger changer
un petit peu la direction pour que ce
soit vraiment ce que à base je voulais
c'est que je me sens vraiment plus
aligné si tu allais pas des dates ici
j'arrête je pense pas eu le petit poucet
de ces petits changements qui tenait sa
soeur
c'est vraiment positif aussi le team
même s'ils vivent cette angoissante
était chiant tu te germaine ton année de
bouquets déjà devant toi que tu sais qui
est wade bout contre de la fable c'est
comme claque plus rien c c c c c est
stressant au point déjà crise majeure
tourner dessus study ou terre des genres
qui fait qu'on est rendus là l'autre
étudiant d'auzan d'autres aux adversités
ja qui aurait rien trouver des solutions
bi mode survie notamment les importune
téléphones sont présentés même fait
défaut qui a quatre fait de la place
aussi qu'as tu fait de la place tel
temps premièrement de réfléchir pi2
d'instiguer des projets qui étaient
vraiment envie de faire ainsi quand tu
es tout en en jute important de faire
ces projets là mais aussi il ya des
choses qui t'arrive c'est plus je joue
pas prise et eric messer juste tu peux
dire oui aux choses qui est qui t'arrive
tu t'es vraiment le goût de fa fa qui
est des fois c'est important de faire un
pull l'espace à la vie pour qui c'est
surprenant ce qui peut être des fois tu
sais pas si
je comprends que ça n'arrive pas si t'as
pas de place pour l'accepter tu le fais
pas tu seras jamais effectué son arrêt
c'est comme s'ils disaient pendant 11
ans t'es gentil push push push mais au
final tic de la cour je sens qu on
appelle ça les pages fan mais ce n'est
pas exactement ce pour le ni-ni sur le
dot qu'en dit le texte exact fait que
même fait de l'espace seinomarins mots
comme ses socios nouvelle
poussée andré lemaître sur un t shirt
c'est aussi la fête l'espace pourrait
équilibrer mais c'est ça faire de
l'espace et c'est parce que c'est ça
aussi
dans ton dans son cercle social parce
que mettons t on a tous une limite de
personnes qui peuvent occuper
notre siège social c'est une autre pour
voir des amis à l'infini ne peut pas
faire du temps de qualité pour du monde
à l'infinity fait clos quand efforcé de
faire de l'espace pour des raisons
logistiques comme la queue vide ça
permet d'autres m'ont aussi de rentrer
dans ton sac social il d'augmenter mais
ça m'est arrivé le vent là que vit le
faire je vais faire la place à la à des
nouvelles personnes qui m'apporte
forking beaucoup puis je n'aurais pas je
n'aurais pas eu cette place le système
avait absolument pas ce que c'est mais
ton avait encore vides et on priorise
justement ton entourage qui était depuis
tellement longtemps qu'ils ont tous plus
de questions puis cse mais justement en
faisant les porte sur soi une excitation
des gens qui te rencontrer le quotidien
c'est vraiment de belles rencontres puis
sa marine beaucoup dans ma vie doit pas
être choqué ses intentions de jeu sa
cause de tempête avait déjà des plans
prévus avec ses dents bourse et fax et
c'est vraiment je commence à m que du
bon que je pense que justement nous
allons parler c'est bien plus de positif
que de négatif le site hub décidé le
tournage on avance et ça c'est l'autre
des bleus sans entrer dans
le
le discours du mindset puis que tout est
dans le monde certes mais c'est vrai
qu'un pion un peu tout quidam mindset
dans risky trop près ni trop loin ni
brandon et brenda
entrepreneuriat
vous apprend comment améliorer votre
ville c'est exactement au final
comment tu voulu comme quel nom tu
donneras commandes les bose l'état
d'esprit
à
agathois oui
métier la vie humaine c'est être en mode
solution dans le fond
non mais non mais
c'est vrai ça mais ne peut pas ce qui
t'arrive jeudi par le corps de rose qui
est arrivé de l'autre les contrôles qui
se fait après de tels choix même de
mettre en mode solution est d'essayer de
faire le moins pire et mettant quelque
chose de ma guitare et faire le mieux
que les choses n'aillent ce qui t'arrive
ou subir le tpiy
c'est tout le monde des réalités
différentes y en a qui l'ont qui se bat
plus rough que d'autres pigeons en train
de non mais mais même sans même se
plaint jeudi seuls du plu aux privilèges
de l'histoire de l'humanité c'est mais
même ce ça s'applique à tout les niveaux
ces mêmes sites même si tu la perds vie
de foi king membre du parc toutes les
prises de ces monarchies cornet y signe
avec sa famille se faire assassiner
devant ses yeux tu puisses constat le
même prix mais se considère privilégié
c'est ça ces facteurs s'est lui comme
levier qui
menacent même reçu ou dix semaines ce
qu'ils aient cessées si les goûts même
genre et bien le pittoresque lui
magnette en mode nouveau tout défoncer
les prix mais lui a
rien qui l'a
littéralement rien
il était arrivé s'ils manient engueuler
positif que jamais aucun sens mon dieu
il était ici pl je reçois un message de
la personne que vous aimez en contact
ces gamins jarrier pas d'ascenseur votre
local dont fait et comme un ascenseur
jusque là le woudy m'appelle denis fait
genre m
je suis devant votre la calle persson
par une bonne photo et jean dans un
appart et de brendan le genre pas loin
d'ici janvier monter un bloc qui avait
pas d'ascenseur ya monté quatre étages
d'escaliers
genre en se levant même puis en montant
son fauteuil pleut il n'était pas bonne
place les faire ok j'arrive plus à y
arrive demain je voi attendant boy
arrivée mme boye faye de sourds il fait
genre salut cousin publié
mardi normal pour moscou mais oui mais
moi je vois ces vidéos le yared paul
temps dans des parcs ou je pense qu'il
était pro-gym je peux courir un jump est
elle sûre c'est tout le temps sur ses
mains on doit vraiment faire des
pirouettes le 5d push up un stand avec
son fauteuil de jambes a dit henri dédie
cet avis à ceux ça amène tes jeudi on
parlait déjà vu personne de plus positif
pour un mythe lui mais ça en découlent
de ce aussi jeudi y est fait et ma
douleur de quoi avec ça et puis en
inspire d'autres jeux des fautes on en
parle en ce moment
c'est classique leur
disais aussi que
avec un conseil vu dans les 30 secondes
qu'on s'est parlé et j'en ai lu des
choses ensemble oui même ça m'a surpris
pas
direct dans le
disait que j'imagine que la démarche du
jusque du n books tout petit peu seul
que tu voulais faire quelque chose qui
allait permettre éventuellement tu te
retirer des de la présence des médias
sociaux m'étonne je sais pas si c'est ce
définitif mais je sais que c'est dans la
bonne voie de ce qu'on a un plan de
retraite de réseaux sociaux on a tous
ses plans mais c'est drôle parce que
justement quand j'en parlais de
smoothies agit souvent comme ça en prend
aussi charmé je peux le seul à penser ça
non mais quand y'en a vraiment qui
excelle là dedans petit ami adrián
qu'ici c'est exact londres est vu que ça
te été donnée enfin j'espère rendre ce
peut être pas nécessairement ce que tu
avais voulu l'idée de l'avoir
sortie d'audi c'est vraiment un ces
mêmes bull mais je dis moi d'être de
danse finalement je réalise qu'il peut
être que le gip a la personnalité pour
être constant la date
exacte le
change de trajectoire qui reste dans mon
thème de bien-être peu importe juste
prendre soin de soi puis da ttc quoique
dans le dense cette boucle c'est que
c'est quoi exactement qui m'a en fait
l'idée m'est venue mettons l'été passé
j'ai fait et dans un rail non mais
pourrait alors chaque matin chaque matin
c'est déjà ça c'est la première chose
que j'ai changé c'est juste je me levais
un an plus tôt puis passer une heure à
rien faire ou juste commencé ma journée
relaxé dans mon café jeux d'encours et
que je commence à ce que tu fais en
vacances n'en sors de ta chambre d'hôtel
petit voit sa place je sais qu'il a fait
pour nous regarde le soleil la seule
raison que je suppose que c'est parce
que je mets mon cadran en octobre dans
le fond ou avec un petit quinté pas en
vacances l'heure exacte exactitude un
petit lait mais tout en dernière minute
pour ton premier rendez-vous où met-on
ce travail
le truchement de très rares cas tout le
temps dans un état misérable sentant
rencontre pas si toujours habitude
d'être dommages et intérêts si j'ai
passé le comme c'est mon université au
congrès en fait jusqu'à la fin de mon
parcours universitaire c'était ma ville
tu te lèves 15 mai avant de partir de
panic mendy
absolument 10 et jeudi une fois que
c'était bac 2 être lancée avec un petit
30 minutes plus tôt brice taton mahut
nord thomas deux ans et j'ai vraiment du
temps dans ma journée pour faire des
choses que je te bute à stresser jeu
tout en haut puis au final se
développent et on sait toute différente
solides sont tes deux pieds avec les
spurs qui était faite puis commence à
développer mais ceci dit hors crise yal
pour moi aussi je suis comme un mets le
matin je me fais pas déranger furs je
fais c'est le trou numéro 10 et je
trouve que je brainstorm le ou des fois
que le style hippie ans a écrit comme ça
quand ça écrivait le tout vient du fait
que dans
supposer qu'ils misent dé planneuse de
notebook ont commencé un matin comme ça
depuis toujours je les fais du match ça
a commencé je devais fin du match pour
d'un mot mettons je faisais beaucoup de
consultations en ligne de training de
jean équilibre de vie mais tant pis je
fais comme je vous fais d'autres choses
que des t-shirts et des t-shirts ou quoi
que ce soit effectué surtout dans cette
sphère halle et quelque chose tu peux
utiliser un outil un autre bouc je
trouve que ça fait ça rassemble toutes
les points ou si c'est un aspect bien
être mental parce que l'idée était le t1
que je le sais pas si je suis libre je
pense même pas le
jj une fréquentation tout l'hiver ce qui
jetait ce plateau je vois à montréal je
vois de l'inspiration des artistes secte
et je vais dans les boutiques je vois
des choses
j'adore ce pilote comme qui m'ont
concept de notebook qui se définit par
geoffrey des modèles exclusifs avec des
couvertures différentes pages en fait
100 copies de modèles y en a plus d'un
titre après ce sera un autre drop un
autre repreneur rapide je veux faire des
collaborations avec des artistes locaux
ou peu importe comme ça je veux que tout
le monde puisse est exprimée lors sur
mettons en place dans son étable où
l'instinct c'est un autre doute pis des
boutiques fin et je veux faire votre
modèle à vous il y en a connus par
ailleurs tu es plus le séquençage des
finish mais moi je trouve pour moi je
trouve ça vraiment est ce parce que
j'aime le changement
j'aime je peux pas rester sur le même
projet le jeudi sam bird fauchage et
j'ai mis plein gémir se diriger ce fax
comme je fais un peu de tout en même
temps depuis ou venant de l'extérieur
quand même
hyper du lieu à n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi mais moi je pense mais ton long
terme comme un jeu tout en même temps
comme si je m'attendais jamais je peux
continuer longtemps été fait que le
design mis mes premiers plane un sursaut
j'apprenne fotopulos tué les trois
méthodes du design d'intérieur
le cover c'est toi qui le les premiers
jeudis c'est moi qui qu'ils aient fait
pis comme jeu je suis pour ce que j'ai
réalisé georges plus artistique que je
pensais si j'avais les skieuses pour
exprimer ce qui me passe par la tête
c'est maintenant sûr illustrer leur
sueur porte un peintre jeu s'est même
posé plein de choses que pleine avenue
que je pourrai ont près tous deux et on
serait sûrement bon on se sent bon dans
quelque chose qu'on n'ait jamais c'est
notre isolement si j'en ai fait un peu
mais je me sens prêt je veux c'est de
trouver le plus de choses que j'aime
pointe-noire fac et le jeu comme un
projet parfait parce que j'y prends je
peux changer à chaque mois deux modèles
j'apprends les nouveaux screens je peux
collaboré avec des artistes à aider des
gens je peux résoudre un problème aussi
ou
améliorer une qualité de vie parce que
mes tempes l'aide de planus de danse
sont vraiment personnalisé furs pour mon
besoin personnel avantages comme un fou
je ne sais pas mais après je le fis
basij tu sais quoi qui l'a devancé quoi
les ce que tu peux entrer là dedans
parce qu'il ya des sections avec
différents objectifs différents ta force
écoute c'est quoi qui a concrètement
dans le planning pipi comment est-ce que
tu l'appeler qu'à ta vie à toi puis
commence que les jambes peuvent
l'appliquer râleur mais si tantôt on
parlait d'un idéal de journée du
dispositif tepa ne pas bouger ne
répondrai pas fait quelque chose tombe
bien n'être ben j'ai essayé de faire un
la structure parfaite pour une journée
parfaite sur moi je commence mon matin à
avec ce jeudi rien faire juste écrit me
dis pas que j'ai comme une section
réflexion du matin on se doute on va pas
se mentir on a tous des responsabilités
faux frères faut avancer ses failles et
des touches plates qu'il ya des choses
qu'on aimerait faire mais qu'on ne prend
pas le temps parce qu'ils ont fait trop
de touches plates et avec 6 trouver la
balance en dessous ce qui met gils en
quatre catégories productivité sociale
parce que c'est des fois faute appelle
sa mère puis tu oublies d'avoir pigeons
et moi je trouve ça vraiment essentiel
pas les mères sont les plus grands
oubliés
de notre génération le cinéma voir en
face à chaque fois que je parle à ma
main ça me fait toujours vraiment du
bien sauf qu'il faut que j'écrive
affaires et tu encore en vie pour
l'interrogation bleus je l'appelle du
sud puis on fait quand même pendant à
peu près 30 minutes 6 1 mais c'est aussi
tout le temps comme rattrapage
[Musique]
mais
activement tous les jours je pense a
marre souvent mais tous les jours at il
aussi moins souvent
factice pour l'aspect social est
important site et c'est juste prendre de
l'avancé des choses qu'on l'a bien qu'on
les écoute on laisse de côté et enfin
que ça fait prendre conscience comme un
remind qui l'aspect social après ce
bien-être ce qui est embêtant c'est le
petit comme tacos ferrand trimestre peut
entraîner situe à court et 10 soit juste
et meilleure preuve exact c'est sa rente
bien manger peu importe ton juste un
glims de ta journée fac ci comme des
mots clés les mots c'est sur une page le
jeu d'ici pâques etc en mode push avec
pilar des catégories c pour soi c'est un
développement personnel mais plus que
cette envie d'apprendre de m me remets
ton tu peux commencer justement témoin
j'ai appris je fais mon petit cours de
l'estuaire est juste pour apprendre une
scène mais ça sert à quelque chose de
plus grand site était quelque chose
devait apprendre quelques pas pris le
temps fax et juste à remettre en
question comme eh ben je vais apprendre
sur tel sujet peu importe que c'est
vraiment un autre aspect développement
personnel que quand vous trop ta cause
productivité n'a pas le temps de phase
finale j'ai pas vu un planeur sont
souvent tout son anglais aussi jeu comme
sur ce que j'ai fait un sondage
franglais français métier j'écris bien
en anglais jeu comme je trouve ça sonne
tous tout mieux en anglais aussi mèche
je comprends le besoin en france eiffage
j'essaie de faire les doutes et puis je
trouve juste qu'il y avait peu de
template y diriger vers une trajectoire
équilibré l'unité balance et c'est toute
votre activité votre séjour est tout à
fait à notre la productivité sur dix
comme ben ça me fait de l'angor le joyau
de la chose dans ville qui finalement
dans la catégorie essais des réflexions
at on ajouté ton à la de la journée
c'est qu'on le mette fini ta journée là
dessus en place des tours ton ciel puis
fini sur une note positive moi ça fait
là plus gros le plus gros changement
pour mon sommeil je me réveille mieux
après c'est comme tout un service yeux
qui s'enchaînent comme je commence ma
journée avec ce que je finis ma journée
avec sa faction cercle vertueux l'invers
délicieux temps
dans faute sur en plus seul avait
moins de moitié moitié entre rempli le
télévie les pensées du matin évidemment
tu es rempli le matin mais maintenant le
plan nord pour ta journée c'est une
matin je me tends à szczesny tombe ça
peut être le matin après joe enfin
goethe en avant-midi matthew goss qui
vont chauffer ce mets tes priorités de
peu les écrits l'avc pas dedans mais
j'ai trouvé aux enfants c'est exact
d'une cause en fin de journée dans parce
qu'une feuille qui voit une journée puis
à la fin la dernière section c'est ma
priorité pour demain flotter comme pas
qu'il réponde ami mr 6e envoi des
documents des choses qui étouffait que
tu la laisses l'ops pense même plus
besoin dans les tunnels comme parfait je
peux dormir en paix lui qui te dit le
joueur ans j'en sors
des justes ligne et qui vont être en
paquet deux parce que tanner qui déjà
dirigé comme j'explique depuis tantôt
mais c'est un président plus de besoins
plus de place des réflexions manière
juste lignée mais genre mon but est que
ce soit
esthétiquement beau bouquet de plus de
laisser traîner sur la table de chevet
c'est à table de salon et sa fille tecmo
mon chez moi c'est vraiment minimale
minimaliste et maxi cela la grosse
thématiques en tout est fait le tout
sortira premier rang puis est sous quel
thème
en fait si le terme
c'est vraiment difficile à comme je
commente eu la plus
solennelle mais c'est juste personnes
rejetées comme hakim parfait jean
réveille même arrivé le matin lever de
soleil prends mon café sa fille tu es
bien c'est l'été tout comme je me sens
vide ce matin tu le nom que tu veux
donner à toutes les plantes c'est le nom
de cette collection le nom cette
collection le mais l'intérieur
j'appellerai tresseur planète libre
mais c'est super intéressant puis ça ça
rejoint ce qu'on disait tantôt tués par
rapport à l'équilibré de pis c'est
d'écrire en moi j'ai tendance à faire
des listes de choses à faire pour la job
pour la business it et que ce soit là le
studio que ce soit même ma business a
moins mais
jamais de la vie je dois écrire appelée
maman jamais jamais mais je trouve ce
crime and bones de vraiment à surprend
je dis oui ça m'a plu saint jean à exact
on était des fois ça peut jouer appelle
un ami de longue date le disait
quelqu'un qui se prend contact ça peut
être
très inquiétant qui jauge socialise un
peu au site et josé le category l'est
vraiment face puis le 6 un planeur j'ai
fait comme ce sympathique savanes en
tout
le jeudi est déjà définie pour le
prochain parce que moi qui aurais
certainement sa
facture que ce que j'aime c'est jeudi je
pense à quelque chose je rajoute dans le
prochain jeu enlevé et et ça reste
jamais le même temps acheter un voleur
mois mais après si tu es comme amel
haute est différent pour d'autres
besoins qui je reprends ici c'est un fax
est un peu
et puis moi ça me garde tout temps
créatif fait c'est vraiment ce que
j'aime tant il ya des applications le
tai chi et te parlais du daf 1 en fin de
journée le 10 comme les fléchettes à
journée il commença a été commandée
sensibles du sud j'avais déjà vu ce type
s'était comme justement ça pose est ce
que c'était une journée oui non pourquoi
plus être comme très bon peu un peu
question mais je sais cool aussi dans le
fret et à l'écrit le journal la main il
ya chaque jour un petit chèque d'esthète
une bonne journée puis george smith
antibes sinon pourquoi parce qu'après ce
cas se pose question là bas c'est comme
qu'est-ce que je règle pour
neymar
c'est un bon point le monde font pas les
réflexions de se poser pourquoi ce
qu'est ce qui va pas loin mais on
compense avec n'importe quoi d'autre
trop mangé pas stressé 6 georges des
problèmes ou la
finale c'est justement faire de l'espace
poser les vraies questions ça amène à
sauter les réflexions mis le feu outre
familier avec ce titre parle de cette
application qui utilise est
intéressé
par un joueur des villas jeu juste de
prendre la 2 secondes pour réfléchir
qu'est ce qui ne se passe pas les
productivité ont parlé d'être dans le
jus pour parler de faire du tas mais
qu'un kit arrête jamais pour réussir bin
hamman et les choses s'enchaînent pis je
suis un tract pour cette question permet
de faire en fin de journée que c'est une
bonne journée non je me suis je connais
ma blonde qui pourrait le muscle avec ma
blonde et cameco pourquoi comment je
pourrais le public avec ma blonde
blessés ça amène des réflexions qui
s'est réglé le problème c'est
ce panier anecdotes personnelles mais il
fait quand une fille d'ivoire puis on a
des petits accrochages des trucs de même
puis je dire jeudi sonne même le monde
qui coûte de l'extérieur encore faire
décrit ses états d'âme c'est ça ça fait
vraiment
un gars qui
mais moi je vois je vois les bienfaits
que ça m'apporte j'étais quand même mais
un accrochage la place de faire c'est de
ta faute cette info c'est ta faute
distance je vous écris rejoint qu'est ce
qui s'est passé puis genre qu'est ce que
moi je trouve que j'ai fait de pas
correct vis versa est tellement des
situations parce qu'après surpal qui
communique clairement ça st c'est fou
comment ça peut améliorer au niveau
communication
clarté aussi de ne pas prendre tout
pointé du doigt en tout en europe a
remis sauveur soif qu'est ce que moi
j'ai manqué ou ce que je pourrai
m'améliorer et je pense que si on
pouvait tous faire ce qu'ils aiment les
relations tellement mieux mais la carte
mmc segre le parce que justement des
fois il arrive de quoi petit trouve pas
exactement le bon mode comme pas
exactement ce que de l'avoir fait une
fois par écrit choisi les bons mots il
faut que ça sort ça ça pour rien qui ait
touché par le tt mettons pas le temps
d'écrire une des lettres à quelqu'un
paie et chaque mot aussi moins de chance
que tu te mettes et puis dans la bouche
que juste comme je te débat les enfants
écrit un texto de jambes et bleu pts des
fastes
mais le fait de le faire une fois ce que
tu as le goût de dire à la personne
avant lui dire c'est sûr que ça va mieux
sortie ouest peut-être checchetto aussi
les jeunes et en cadets qui satisfait
gens renoncent était capable de débattre
envers toi même de l'idée que tu viens
d'avancé maintenant mais quand tu sors
ça à l'oral sans avoir jamais et qui
semble n'y avoir jamais vraiment pensé
avant
tu vas dire quelque chose que même tout
est capable de démonter
dernier argument qui a lancé ce genre
chikh el cheikh est ce que je vienne
isère ça fait pas de sens sauf que
d'années que je l'avais jamais dit je
m'étais jamais rendu compte que ça
faisait pas de sens bien au moment où ça
sort de ta bouche fhf
c'est comme si vraiment les pots cassés
j'ai comme puis en faisant ce des
réflexions jeudi c'est peu c'est encore
là c'est une question de tempérament
aussi tu es moche chicane vraiment les
deux bagues non sens que je peins pis si
je peux lever le ton je peux me chicaner
je vais toujours de mon bord jouer comme
qu'est ce qui motive un peu creux
qu'est-ce que je pense qu' on pourrait
améliorer et et qui au final sauver un
système juste d'un quentin puis
silence tout explose le trafic ne faut
jurer que ce qu'il faut parler de la
situation qui a provoqué ce type comme
deux systèmes avancés pour ce qui est
quand même parce que mu c'est miss kiss
des communications tellement amélioré je
savais que en vous comme relationnel de
choix pour cela
je trouve ce moment est-ce parce que
quand je rencontre quelqu'un qui est pas
nécessairement
qui moi j'étais vraiment fermé je parle
pas de mes émotions non plus pu temps
plus tard avant ce sujet plus d'écho qui
vit plus à l'aise vient
quand je faisais tu connais un peu mieux
au sipi la personne qui te rends compte
si toi tu as tu stade là aussi été rendu
à l'aspi d'autres personnes est fermé
mais qui peut l'amener associe la à
s'ouvrir puis à faire comme hey joe pas
je porterai d'en face si tu me dis que
la fin c'est où merci on va pas je peux
te donner de la marde si on faisait la
file comme on peut je trouve que ça
amène les sports aux personnes qui ont
toujours été dans les relations ceux qui
se font taper sa tête ils font s'ils
font ce fait que sarah même si des fois
ça peut être quand même
ça peut être déstabilisant
quelqu'un qui ont ce camp tout le poids
fame étant quelqu'un qui arrive qui dit
ouvertement ce sont ses états d'âme
puisque cent par rapport à vous soit
votre relation à sa vie puis tout est
comme tmg pas grandi dans une dans un
monde où est ce qu'on disait vraiment
nos émotions laitiers et le contre quand
j'arrive dans un sip de gens qui sait ce
qu'ils font
c'est déstabilisant ces genres crise qui
jeu mais en même temps vous avez l'air
bail en tabarnak à faire ce fake et je
commençais alfort pratique en salle
force ou
quel est ce sentiment des jarres de
légèreté puis
d'humanité exemple autour de sortie puis
c'est juste positif vous a appris mais
ça après une rupture puis ça a pris ces
scènes chez la psy pour réaliser à quel
point ça faisait du bien de s'ouvrir
parce que j'avais tout cas plus il
grille qui communiquait pas tant que ce
polita de la bonne manière et surtout
pour le pire mais loin d'être la
meilleure arme et on pige à
amani jeter comme les chargés d'affaires
ressortent le style plus frais ça ça
j'allais chez un psy plus ça a été trois
premières séances une heure déjà
moi qui parle non stop le sahara et pij
ans a été jeté les six fois parce
qu'après c'est ça ce que ça donnait pub
de 2 le fait au final c'est peut-être
possible au sommet être bref tout ça te
débloquer mais ça m'a vraiment débloqué
genre déjà six fois une heure de genre
tout de sortir peu près ça c'est comme
crise ça fait du bien de sortir ça fait
bien à être honnêtes avec le monde à
100% internet etc soit même à 100% ça
fait du bien
ça ça change tout le temps faim qui
pousse à être c'est un jour de déclic
après ceux comme toi genre miss cruz de
communication je pense qu'ils ont créé
ce m'améliorer parce que
je mange sage c'était une révélation qui
existe comme ceux qu'ont cinq ans qu'on
du genre ouvert et transparent en arrêt
depuis
qu'ils dépensent que la personne n'a pas
nécessairement bien nous recevoir s'ils
ont souvent mais c'est juste on assume
beaucoup mais au final pour le faire
dans tous les cas ça y est reparti
exemple folle tu vas partir ça arrive ça
arrive c'est mal reçus tout à fait la
bonne affaire exact c'est tout le temps
mieux d'être honnête d'être toi même
d'être vrai peut-être de dire comment tu
sais que je peux le faire même si ça
peut en guinée je mets des guillemets de
nuit parce qu il ajouté au final ça
n'ira jamais jour la bonne chose à faire
mais c'est la personne s'il deux
personnes dans une relation son pot même
même aplomb soumettons maturité
émotionnelle au même niveau de maturité
émotionnelle ça se paye un clash mais
faut pas d'engrais maturité émotionnelle
pour fêter avec l'autre non c'est 5 6
comme cette le pays si c'est toi qui te
plus soit 17 le ps pis je dis moi ça
vient du fait que j'ai souvent été
fermés j'avais pas des réactions des
gens de ce que j'allais dire presque moi
j'ai envie du projet pas de décevoir
jean jé pas d impact que ça va faire
terminer une relation aussi jusqu'à
l'iphone d'apple georges a dit tout ce
que je pense ou la vie de la même façon
la bonne saison la bonne façon c'est
parce que tous dit mais ça prend juste
la bonne façon de le dire il faut c'est
camara qui s'est abîmé peu avant
d'ajouter ce direct pendant deux jours
puis revient et se met au final si tu en
parles peut sacrer des futurs on parle
au début début leur parler de quelqu'un
qui sape pigeon c'est qu'on le mette un
détail qui est en parle peu par an deux
ans après ça va exploser jeudi c'est un
détail qui est jamais à bord et cela
dressé s'est dit si c'est un détail je
dire vraiment 10 il
exact que mettons ces dandys toi tu
évites de dire des choses je vous dis
qu'ils appréhendent d'avant-garde pour
toi ça va péter
fake c'est pour ça que je fais mais
j'aime mieux si ça va péter ça va péter
là mais au moins je vais avoir exprimé
ce que j ai envie de dire au moment que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que je rende le
géant sport comment la vive hausse
possible comme moi je veux mettre mes
paramètres puis
tantôt si tu respectes là dedans je dis
faut que l'autre personne fasse ok
parfait mais bon si je dis ce que je
pense qu après un échange dont exemple
sinon je dis pas ça marche pas juste
d'un bord ou non si ça c'est pas un
directionnel puis pour pour reprendre
ce qu'on disait par rapport à
en fait pour reprendre l'exemple
vraiment cave de ligue 1 qui ça tombe à
l'eau début
il ya aussi un travail oui dans la
communication mettant quelque chose qui
dérange vraiment capable de l'exprimer
correctement comme tu le sens mais il y
aussi une année dicte à avoir envers toi
même puis à double check et dire à quel
point c'est important puis pourquoi est
ce que c'est important pour toi c'est
avec mes temps quelqu'un qui sape les
deux frères ok ça mène à quai à quel
point ça ménard puis est ce que vraiment
ça m'énerve parce que je le laisse
m'énerver puis si c'est le cas est-ce
que je peux pas travailler ça à plat sa
place de demander à quelqu'un d'autre
d'arrêter de saper alors que c'est pas
grave dans ses piques ça change rien
soyez quand même vous ce travail est un
travail à fond ce rapport à soi pour
être capable d'évaluer déjà qui se sent
gosse
ceci grâce et ceux d'entre eux quoi
s'ajoutent gospi pièce que gère le parti
vert dessus puisque un passé par dessus
mais il faut que je passe par dessus
mais la défense dans un autre état
d'esprit qui comme le jeu l'entente
comme pu noter ouais mais quand cela
mène esprit de famille tout le monde
l'entend à ses seuls
éclairs
le test de noël c'est le test gens on a
parlé l'autre fois de dire de ces mets
ton
moi je vais repartir sur autre chose
mais moi mettons je suis rendu
de par mes discussions dans la dernière
année dans le dernier dernières années
et demi je suis rendu à un moment riche
j'ai accepté un petit peu plus toutes
les modes de vie matonge accès plus
tout ce que touche plus ouvert d'esprit
le train puis impression parler de tes
quand tu viens quand vient le temps de
se mettre en couple mais tombée dessus
je suis vraiment proches ma famille
encore aujourd'hui tu joues un message
en mai par un vrai cadre en carbone puis
à noël on encore vraiment projet fait
que me dit la personne que je veux avec
qui je m en coupe metton est-ce qu'ils
passent le test du suspect neil parce
que moi mettons dans ma vie personnelle
je prêt à accepter beaucoup de
deux personnes conneries disque une
route personne différente avec des
mentalités de faire en étant je suis
ouvert d'esprit quand même sauf que je
suis aussi vraiment en proximité avec ma
famille puis les valeurs qui m'ont été
inculquées dont puisqu'une personne que
je vois pas le test du pénal dans ce
sens que je suis vraiment content et
cette personne arrive avec moins
à noël chez sa famille puis rencontre
tout les gens qui sont le plus chers
pour moi si la réponse un bémol
peut-être que j'ai une question posée
par rapport à cette relation le parce
qu'il ya peut-être quelque chose de
fondamental qui fait pas avec
l'idée que j'ai avec le test urinaire et
puis souvent plus probant que ta famille
ils vont l'accueillir brou va à bourg va
mais c'est juste toi mais ton ressenti
de légers malaises à durer sans une once
de malaise il ya peut-être quelque chose
kaka encore une fois tu tues value le
pignon mettons de ta famille noah quand
des proches qui est important pour toi
les valses
meiway l'espèce humaine elle faut quand
même se poser certaines questions tout
était prêt personnellement mais
peut-être que tu es valeurs
fondamentales qui ont été inculquées
bataille que tu peux lire mettent en
question aussi
mais peut-être aussi que ça me tente pas
que tu es proche de paris 8ème tome ses
valeurs la même taille au final c'est
plus toi tu es au final moins l'effet
criquet team et on dit mettons
maintenant je travaille sur une tournée
puis le travail que seul le sup le à
management ariba de la tour je travaille
dessus puis des fois c'est au moment de
la faire écouter quelqu'un d'autre ait
dit oh le jeu l'écoutent mais quelqu'un
d'autre dans la pièce plus l'écouteur
piège je le sais qu'il ya beaucoup de ça
marche pas au sport pile après
640 travail qu'ils soient finis puis la
pression justifiée mais fait 4-5 la
tournée vol et le écoute soit votre ip
plein trip mais 4d foutisme à toi moi
même d'être annoncé est une bonne toune
finalement ta montre au monde ce fait à
[Applaudissements]
si le test public à publier dans
le fond tu le savais mais tous les potes
l avouer qu'à caracas
à trouver des excuses pour ce que tu es
pas fiable à 100 % c'est encore c'est le
premier
vrai que le premier jet
mais si je devais le s'amène et des
malts avance aussi le jeu des fautes à
passer
tout
représentant bactéries avec ta famille
avec le tpiy foot what they la personne
qui est du partage ta vie
soit pitié à l'égard de partager ta vie
de ces personnes
qui à l'extrême c'est des fois t'es on
en est souvent que des exemples de
genève est très peu simple on met à
chennai gentil ça vient paquet deux je
les mettrai pas son permis il ya peu
mais les hanter mais tu es comme des
fois été dans cette situation la petite
pause à qui ce que je suis ce genre de
personnage va pu inviter à cause de
telle offre comme est ce que je suis
bien représentée ici en rut et qui est
ce que moi ça m'arrive quand même d'être
posée si ça va nous poser ces questions
le rush comme le chiendent ou peut-être
une tête c'est moi qui me fais des
scénarios même tâche comme je vois de
l'extérieur qu'est ce que ça peut donner
puis c'est comme si j'ai pas envie
chez pas je veux quelqu'un me représente
à 100% et je peux te les 100% confiance
en toi vas voir jouer mais pas rien à
[ __ ] hall ce
que tu dis là
je l'aï vécue souvent
ya pas une fois que j'ai vécu ce
sentiment là de comme
avoir
un petit malaise de genre comme la
personne avec qui je suis je comme un
peu genre
casse dans mon groupe d'amis de corps le
suc sont là depuis vraiment longtemps
puis
une des affaires que j'ai réalisé avec
aude et puis en sortant de l'eau des
puits tout le tourbillon qui arrive puis
comment tu peux de perdre facilement ces
choses de
les amis c'est vraiment un tchèque
pour ce genre d'affaires le les groupes
d'amis qui étaient là avant si tu
ressens
une petite affaire de comme le choucas
met dans une situation sociale puis je
sens que ceux qui étaient là avant
voyez qu'il ya quelque chose qui me rend
mal même même pas maintenant par rapport
à
aux personnes avec qui j'étais ou juste
envers moi même de faire yocum de quoi
kiwi un peu puis moi dans ma tête ça a
pris du temps avant de comprendre ça
sérieusement a pris deux ans dans ma
tête de faire ses petites affaires le il
faut que je la considère c'est parce que
moi je le temps c'est du revers mais
même si on m'a changé un peu inquiet
puis peut-être que le jab et ailleurs au
pays on ça fait longtemps qu'on s'est
pas vu mais cette affaire le nom pour ce
n'était pas si c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
me connaît et sait ce qu'elle veut un
chèque de comme si moi je me sens mal à
l'aise en vareuse haut c'est ma faute à
moi parce qu'ils n'ont pas chanté jeudi
la dynamique il n'y a pas de raison que
ça ait changé de son petit ami de longue
date pour rien c'est vraiment quelque
chose c'est ce qui fait qu'il est à
manille si ça fait plus c'est parce que
tu as perdu ton il ya quelque chose
c'est ce exact - puis souvent pas des
bonnes amitiés juste parce qu'on on
n'est pas attentif à ce genre de cech
exactement
ce qu'on me foute vais passer tentons
blanc de ton thiam table on a 20 ans et
mes amis c'est eux qui ont par rapport
ces outils ont par rapport celle qui
connaît depuis tellement longtemps que
tu vas tu as et des amis ouvre ta blonde
que tu connais depuis six mois c'est
complètement moi ce que moi je trouve
rationnellement ça fait pas de sens tu
comment tu vas t'en vouloir ta vie tes
amis c'est là pour toujours dahmane je
dis qu'on est jeunes on sait pas l'amour
saveurs exister exact ça doit pas être
un choix à faire non c'est celle qui
n'ont cessé sauf que sauf que si le
choix tu le fais un peu de façon c'est
moi moi mettons la télé je le sais pas
on attendait de mes amis de l'université
c'est ce groupe d'amis la québec
krismenn g voyez moins souvent au
mètre près après audit après au dg voyez
moins souvent parce que parce que je me
disais
il ya quelque chose qui cloche c'est
comme souvent une chose les tiges qui
gère voyait des fois puis quand je sais
si c'est ça c'est parce qu'il y avait
quelque chose puis j'ai envoyé moins
souvent ces faits ne veut pas la
décision c'est comme prise 1 malgré -
2-2 juste pas vouloir me remettre dans
ce que je décrivais comme la situation
parce que je me sens un peu il ya
quelque chose qui cloche pauvre l'on me
remettre dans cette situation là par la
force des choses j rumeau souvent la
place de moins me questionner farc alan
jara enlevé ce qui cloche que j'ai le
même confort avec ces gens luttent
fonctionnement est un tchèque qu'il faut
pas ignorer qui est importante c'est
parce que comme tu dis
le monde sur l'eau depuis le début ils
se disent qu'après sept ans le monde que
tu dis que tu es dans ta vie après
pendant sept ans il célèbre la vie s'est
fait des amis mes tongs doit pendant
sept ans après ce
dans dix ans je pourrais pas y voir
pendant 10 ans puis vont ils vont être
lésés mais encore exact
c'est que l'on mange j'y parlais à mes
potes qui rendu en norvège a fait un
instit boîte qui habite le
puits lui il disait que
met-on sylphide l'épaule il appelle
encore ses amis au québec parce qu'il
n'est pas d'amis en norvège qui sent
confortable d'appeler s'il fait le parti
fait qu'il se fait longtemps qu'ils
étaient encore vivants et je note on le
voit pu me j par une fois par facetime
par année mais ils m'appelleraient moins
ça va pas voir avant de parler du monde
là bas parce que ça fait longtemps que
je te tue le jeu va être là tout le
temps ce monde là et comme de caunes
inconditionnels qui la donnent
absolument c'est tellement il faut
tellement poli les sous-estimer parce
que même moi des fois je me mets dans
cette position là devant as fait
tellement longtemps je peux parler que
je me sens mal je me sens mal de 8
charte des fois je me dis ah il ya dix
tourné le dos jeudi j'ai dû me barrer de
la liste je vis des fois je sens un peu
c'est cette culpabilité le défunt
quand je me suis absenté un petit peu
trop j'ai pas pris de nouvelle mais
après je me pose la question - mais j'ai
pas une nouvelle non plus utile accès
comme un échange a deux je pense que je
trouve que c'est pas pour toi mais après
après audi on dirait qu'il ya beaucoup
d'amitié chambranlante que c'était comme
ok mais je n'hésitais pas à même de
comprendre que j'ai moins de
disponibilité le mais je sais comment il
faut que je n'ai pas à me justifier t
mon bonbon il était mon bon chemin jeudi
puisque ça fait des frictions de
devrait comprendre si je pose est
expliquée comme la famille je veux dire
je peux le ch - le gpra d'enfants qui se
passe nouvelle blanc nouvelle vie s'ils
se tester sur qui
et et le pot lengronne je vous dit
comprendre qu'il valait moi j'en
retiendrai jamais rigueur à des gens qui
je parle plus pendant six mois qui ont
fait leur qui ont avancé leur vie et
watson qu'est ce qui se passe de lutte
et j'en ressens mais c'est sûr que le
concept d'un s'attend à quelque chose
moi c'est ça l'amitié ça va ça devrait
être inconditionnel au sens où
chacun vit sa vie individuellement aussi
le tir n'était pas besoin c'est sûr que
c'est sûr que moi ça m'est arrivé des
amis qui qui qui avait une nouvelle
blonde qui me parle plus je trouvais ça
plate mais au final ce sont ces gens là
sont aujourd'hui ils sont plus dans ma
vie le thé dansant si on n'était pas ce
genre de d'amitié l'heure dans le fond
mais j'ai juste trouvé sa place parce
que là on avait une belle relation mais
au final c'était pas une relation qui
accueillait ce qui était dû pour durer
10 ml
c'est des amis amis mais n'en a pas
besoin non c'est ça s'est fait sur le
mode
permettant de mieux c'est sûr qu'on peut
pas ce bâtiment notre vie ensemble sauf
que il pays bas ils vont pourrait pas se
parler pendant cinq ans ce serait ouvrir
en tabarnak il y aurait sûrement quelque
chose qui déclencherait cela tient sauf
que si après cinq ans après son passé
sur sa réputée sûre que ça va revenir
bien sûr sur l'axé mais c'est pas tout
le monde d'ici peu toutes les amitiés
puisque toutes les relations aussi
qu'ils sont même pas immortels mais
qu'ils sont inconscients du jeu là c'est
juste des saisies bon moment voire à et
ce je peux mettre trop d'eau là dedans
parce que moi grandir parce qu'il faut
voter où tout change de trajectoire
c'est comme un jeu mani marley l'autre
personne sans ligne complètement à
l'opposé mais on va pas se mentir le
jeudi en soirée moins qu'ils arrivent
c'est pas triste je suis j'ai eu un
message comme ça et écrira keaton bref
qu'à partager ma vie un certain moment
déjà la personne me reprocher à moi puis
quelqu'un d'autre d'avoir juste comme un
peu disparu de sa vie tu sais ça sent
vraiment dans les nouvelles ou répond
nouriture et puis moi lorsque j'ai juste
dit ça y est je pense que
je pense c'est rien contre toi le sait
je pense nous visons vraiment évolué de
façon différente pis que je vais pas
nécessairement puis le g10 un mot pour
mot quasiment les tiges en réponse
allant prendre du temps que j'ai pas
pour des amis vraiment proche pour toi
mais en même temps s'ils participent non
mais ces poches mais comme c'est vrai
piège très bon dieu merci de me dire ça
je trouve ça dommage mais merci de le
dire c'est quand même super ses succès
passés mais un examen réalisé comme le
messager fait conforme cité mais il n'y
a pas d'autre part d'expliquer ça non
plus annoncé s'être qu'un autre matthew
goss et sinon le sugo celui-là sursis
nous tiens puis c'est d'avoir un certain
que le joueur parte en attaque tout le
monde ça revient ce qu'on dise non vers
une transparence d'honnêteté un beau
loupé un bon look eroglu depuis tantôt
en outre piemme tentons
ton texte bouquet dessus bâtons en bois
comme tous l'appellent tandis que le
journal bonjour bonjour mais en anglais
tout sonne mieux en anglais pour moi
puis le calepin quel est donc alten
est une bonne réception les gens sont
tués dans l'oeuf est convié le premier
promis j'ai fait un peu plus que sans
son lot sur des
horaires très cool qui je pense est
juste vraiment différent de ce qu
helmand ont vu ou c'est geof quelque
chose je commence peut-être qu'on
s'attend pas à ça de moi maintenant mais
on se doit
de boxe
mais c'est pour se quitter comme ça me
draguer cherche un oui georges était
parfois de quoi différents puis que je
puisse m'épanouir dans un projet qui
touche à tout l'espoir qui j'aime bien
dans une créativité article artistique t
faire rentrer des jeunes en
collaboration là dedans puis franchement
j'en parle je pense que j'étais excité
comme je dire ça fait longtemps que j'ai
pas eu le feeling comme ceux par mois un
projet ti puis way pour eux la réception
c'est vraiment comme comme le monde s'il
savait pas qu'elle ait besoin de tuyaux
en fait je pense qu'ils ont besoin de
tirs dans ma vie mais oui ça amène un
autre dimension s'amène banquiers comme
qui s'est fait je voulais le faire d'une
façon peu intimidante passent des fois
t'es comme karine d'autres villes de
vous se remplissent à gauche qu'on le
sait comme ceux des guidelines des kamas
qui est rien deux phrases à et créer
creed 2 frogs puis c'est aussi la
pratique de postes jugés quand on écrit
falloir ainsi de l'avant là je les
répare et puis après les bonnes idées
surtout peu importe et puis c'est
vraiment je trouve qu'il sur 90 jours
celui celui le compare le sun rays qui
seront une pratique de trois mosquées
bent
tautou tchèque 3 ans fait ce que ça va
trois mois c'est sûr que ça va changer
d'avis donc on s'en parle jamais essayé
seul messi pendant trois mois tu fais
vraiment l'exercice de faire tout seul
d'être honnête envers le processus ça va
changer ta vie j'ai aucun d'eux aucun
doute que ça peut changer une ville
absolument plus juste que c'est vraiment
sous-estimé
dix minutes dans ma journée pour écrire
sur un bout de papier ça va pas changer
grand chose ouah mais c'est pas
nécessairement des crises et le temps le
moment tu prends autour de tuer c'est
comme moi mais c'est ça ça inclut de
mettre mon celle de côté prenez un
moment vraiment relax parce que payet a
peut-être pour écrire des choses censées
c'est un concorde avec ton fils de
penser et puis tu t'assois sur une
composition écrite des fautes et d'y
progresser progresser de passer comme
fou je trouve le moment pourrait dans un
flou mais là c'est comme contiennent à
chaque jour d'être dans un mini faut à
chaque fois que tu restes là dedans fax
à créer un momentum puisque je consolidé
de la veille je conduis je regarde le
trois semaines qu'est ce qu'on trouve
quelque chose c'est exact puisque homme
a faim se regarde ce que les pages de
tic à sorgues et surtout au début versus
à la fin c'est j'en ai rempli des
cahiers de notes pendant quarantaine
puis je le dis des choses de juin 26 ans
le 20 avril bien géré lui j'avais écrit
des choses le 20 avril à mes 25 ans j'ai
relu ce chat c'est quand même
cc c'est beau de voir ce gantois plus
jeunes puis à présent tu évolues moi je
pense dans mes temps je construis c'est
dans dix ans je voudrais jaune à rodez
c'est comme un humain ton évolution
entre les temps une des affaires
je parlais de ça avec cendrier dans
leurs mains ce qui est un ami proche
maintenant
lui écoutez le livre de réécouter les
délits de mathieu mes conneries malades
qui lui dit mathieu koné et dit lui
faire du jogging depuis longtemps puis
une métaphore qui m'a le plus frappé
c'était
la chose qui lui mettant retrouver le
plus dans ces journaux austère et est
capable de se porter le moment à qui ce
moment là j'étais vraiment bien plaisait
ses journaux il y disait qu'est ce qui
se passe dans ma vie à ce moment là
qu'ils étaient proches de moins
qu'est ce que je faisais au quotidien
quels étaient les projets qui me faisait
comme ce puits inversement les poses qui
était moins contents qu'ils étaient dans
ma vie qu'est ce que je faisais quelles
étaient mes projets plus de 40 de revoir
mettons pendant ce lustre comme 40 ans
de notre pire tourné pendant 40 ans pied
très hâte de voir tout les spots deux
ont maintenant quand je fais le pas bien
géré si c'est quoi le genre d'affaires à
méfier ça c'est que je les vis que
souvent je capable de l'europe des
dénominateurs communs à tous les moments
où est ce que je me sentais pas bien qui
c'est hallucinant qu'est-ce qui ça fait
pivoter son lit piller leur écoute et
que c'est lui qui lisent celle là voilà
les gens qui moi ça me j'étais
exactement dans une fosse de j'écrivais
trois pages par jour je commence à
agiter faire son jogging après ce crash
et je vais écouter son livre si ça me
frappe y jeter genre oh my god c'est
exactement ce que je fais mais leur plus
jeune que lui mais si je continue à son
âge c'est la même affaire lui qui son
livre parce qu'il est sorti son ancienne
boîte album souvenir dans 10 mai de deux
notebooks et qui comme j'écris un livre
avec mes racines tout de suite moi je
trouve ça incroyable c'est fou après
c'est d'avoir ce type tard dans la vie
toute cette documentation le sont agiles
et ex pour tourner à qui a retourné à
2003 allait l'être humain dans le
feeling qui s'arrête c'est encore plus
plus profonde est une photo souvenir oui
ouais parce que sa photo je voudrais moi
des fois j'ai pris des photos est ce que
ça allait pas bien que je l'air d'avoir
du fun de le tuer ou lin ou un verre cet
été j'ai pris des photos est ce que j'ai
l'air de pas banal et puisque meilleurs
moments de ma vie à 8 6 puis non seat 26
seront incorporés puis tu mets ton
business wise men un
carnet de 90 jours
tu fais un nouveau carnet à chaque mois
un estivant business plan parce que le
monde y prennent une habitude 82 chevaux
puis c'est le genre d'attitude qu'est ce
que tu fais pour vrai pour pouvoir
arrêter après exacte avec leurs mains
après ce avec une nouvelle collection
nouveau design seat c'est vraiment cool
plein même pauvre est ainsi un niveau
proche de 90 jours cécile pas que ça
apprendre qu'une nouvelle habitude soit
intégrée c'est parti les trois semaines
321 jours assez bon genre et méthon mais
pour
la bonne dame est temps d'arrêter de
manger du sucre et des bonbons pour que
tu avais plus envie de la faire la
soirée très chic
c'est bon ils sont sûrement plus beau
mais moi si ça quand j'arrête de manger
vous mettons des bonbons ces 21 jours
avant que le soir j'arrive chez nous
puis chauffage a joué à lodève match les
membres mais j'avais déjà entendu ou lu
tes qui aimait tant pour le mettons pour
l'entraîneur que doit savoir puisque moi
la team est tombé pour vraiment qu'est
la routine de l'entraînement sans la
grippe qui tuent garde rigueur pendant
longtemps
après un bon trou au motel le fait assez
humain et des bonnes chances que tu
gardes à l'aise sur les agrès sol et ici
je pense que maintenant ce que ph parler
du succès comme des micros habitude
une micro abhisit doit promettre un jour
mais c'est dans le maquereau thon
ensemble de la vie de moins traumatisant
journée vraiment comment tu conditionne
son journal se fait probablement
assidûment pendant 90 jours de bonnes
chances que de continuer avec la wii si
c'est vrai c'est exact pisté tel point
que j'étais comme un mois ça donne un
cahier trop petit tu veux trois mois
c'est parfait c'est comme si on l'ignoré
encore danny granger est ce par philippe
rey se tient si c'est un fait quand j'ai
pensé à cette business plan de chasse
est infini jugé trop d'idées en ce
moment je peux faire un six mois pour
faire un an je peux faire pour les
étudiants pour l'école du comment cela
rentrée geoffrey compagnon d'études
parce que comme je rentrais ce terme là
c'est vraiment comme un compagnon ce qu'
ils vraiment format de poche sur un
acteur n'importe où ou tipi je voulais
le garder vraiment con si beau pendant
qu'on veut c'est une
personne tout le monde que je connais
qu'un agent de gros comme ça on le voit
paul mais je voudrais que je parle
ingénieurs les uns des clashs et équipe
dense et paix comme une brique ce cas tu
finis jamais centro ces encombrants et
c'est petit c'est con si ça répond à un
besoin précis pas fait c'est vraiment
rotman je trouve comme tu en parles tu
en parles tu là explique bien
tutu vit toi même ton besoin qu'on parle
de toi c'est vraiment aussi gérard
houllier beau en plus celui qui te fait
mais là c'est à chaque mouvement farnaud
tu vois le saladier sortir le premier à
la faillite le 20 avril le ch comme le
sait demain dans le fond le disent sans
juin je fais le deuxième lancement ça a
pris passez le faut je me thème avec moi
comme menaçant près enfin le design
reprend toujours from scratch un peu
parce que je comme ça c'est moi qui trop
perfectionniste je me sens un peu comme
un scam jeu ça je changeais de
corruption photo jean-marie quelque
chose d'un peu de dates qui je trouve je
prends
c'est maintenant le fait que ce soit des
éditions limitées je trouve cela dit
quand même que même si l'intérieur est
pareil si leur art work change et est-ce
que l'intérieur changé aussi mettons est
ce que le ski et du design à l'intérieur
il ya des couleurs mettant les pages de
séparation en coulant jamais toujours
puisque les couleurs changent selon la
préfecture mais moi je trouve ça déjà
vraiment pile le monde le monde qui
collectionne qu'ils font mais on va voir
une évolution de tester ce délice ritter
lettre avec des artistes aussi mais seul
e si je vous ai évidemment on pense à
pogny gens qui traînent les pieds mais
ton de faire une collab avec avec
quelqu'un de même avec des artistes
émergents où les plus urgentes le mec
des artistes qui sont émergents aussi
arrêtons ça devient vraiment rock
c'est josé c'est fou parce que au début
quand juste idée le j'écris mon business
lunch comme hey ok parfait j'ai pas
envie de faire de quand je faisais mes
tomber mais collaborer lt mettons en jeu
fin de campagne marketing mais je
rejoins ph tous écouté besoin d'en
journée qu'est ce que tu veux gens à qui
on veut le design est ensemble puis le
retour et ça va être ce qui te présente
à tout va qu'il va avoir juste le toit
qui est le jean paquin personnes dotées
même chose pour n'importe qui qui veut
je dire tout le monde a des besoins
spéciaux devraient juste moi qui est le
mien mais josette on design intérieur on
le design est ensemble c seront tes
besoins à tous il va pas se reproduire
pour quelqu'un qui ne commencera
qu'après je dis souvent on se fait
envoyer des trucs qui va supprimer comme
axa me représente pas vraiment et puis
je vous le dis comme je le dis pour toi
par toi sur quelques mois c'est si les
ventes hors jeu des campagnes de
marketing ça serait dedans c'est dans
cette optique le christ a toujours un
humain d'amener mais ton soutif en
campagne et on s'est fait hacker la
collection de ce mois ci le je prends
mon exemple la cohésion ce mois ci avec
ph puis dans la collection ce mois ci il
ya comme une bulle hambourg où est-ce
qu'ils le tuent marque mettons à chaque
fois du marteau ou son objectif pour
l'année
la seule façon que je capable de
m'entraîner assidûment puis ça me fait
vraiment du bien de l'entraînement tous
les jours c'est d'avoir un objectif si
j'ai pas d'objectif mettons de
performance en guillemets jugé la mesure
allait montrer métier fait que la môme
et on sait le marathon de québec manqué
de détroit que tu fais le titre aura
pour seul en ce moment là c'est ce que
je fais puis se met ton
mettons se dire qu'est la collection
rien le sujet de la merde collection
avec ph mais non parce que là en bas à
droite un commandant le truc où met-on
tu l'écris en moins le même ça serait
mieux si on commet dans le truc qui
marque son objectif qui est en bas à
droite de toutes les pages fait qu'à
chaque fois que tu tournes une nouvelle
journée tu te rappeler c'est quoi ton
objectif afin du 3 mois maintenant fait
que ça permet à chaque ça chaque jour de
te réveiller de revoir ce la fameuse
technique de michael phelps qui mettait
les records du monde sur son plafond de
chambre pour le se réveillant les
regardant mes métiers mettons imagine tu
fais des quarts avec du monde puis
chaque personne pendant ce mois là où
pendant ce carnet ajoute une petite
affaire
klim six mois je trouve l'idée vienne si
on en parle depuis comme se décider
sûrement que toute française et j'écris
des taux nous peu importe car il ya des
choses qui me passe par la tête cc il ya
de la façon que j'étais comme je vais
approcher les artistes pitou finalement
c'est lui qui maîtrise vraiment j'ai
fait moi-même leurs collabos le design
est aussi l'intérêt pour le français
comme j'en ai une coupe on going en ce
moment d'autres succès si on les
travaille à son fax adeline mais j'ai
comme des partenaires cinq départs
gauche comme s'ils savaient ton ton
plateau qui tu représentes dangereux
sans copie on en fait 100 copies pions
lyvan je dis ça va être demandée qui au
final comme je partage les tâches piste
juste moins pire nous sommes inquiets
c'est est ce que c'est un beau projet
qui est cool d'avoir quelqu'un que
trouver même quelque chose qu'il fait
vraiment vibrer
commentant par lequel jean triplettes et
puis hein ces femmes sa fille folle avec
toi puis
un versement faire parler parce que je
pense pas souvent une question non plus
pas à passer jusqu'à ma seule amie des
mails justement comme de poser des
questions vous êtes intéressé ou si
c'est le fun à voir comme la réception
ce genre de truc qu'on n'utilisera pas
vraiment le fait qu'ils aient fait que
sur scène par le petit rond et on a un
esprit deux athlètes le tournant que de
lille ii on était entre le péage parce
que moi mettez de l'atteinte d'objectifs
de tous ceux de ses puits la constance
qu'il fait d'avoir seul un jour un
journal puis deux à chaque jour
rentrer là dedans ça contribue vraiment
dans la main et que c'est vraiment un
coup si tu as tout parler de
ces deux méthodes et cris de le faire là
bas tu as apple's par quelque chose
qu'il faut continuer petit palais aussi
des écritures de tonnes puis il y avait
un livre ça m'a fait penser à un livre
sur l'écriture des paroles j'avais lu
pizza chaque matin même et on faire un
dix minutes
d'écriture automatique telle écrire
n'importe quoi dès qu'ils passent par la
tête puis disait l autre d après 10
minutes à l'aide qu'ils continuent pas
parce qu'après ce fait d'avoir arrêté
près rarement ça continue toute la
journée c'est comme si le fait d'avoir
un peu plus tôt de sortir tu es obligé
cause du passé puis tout le groupe
construit la menthe et des fois aussi
c'est un 3 heures une fois
les brûler c'est comme acquéreur mais
les armements ben trop d'énergie par
semaine 10 minutes isin ces facteurs le
fait que ça se remplissent vite tacle à
claques mais après ça c'est comme tout
le reste de la journée si les idées
contenues à ce que tu es ce que tu aimes
la marque toute la journée ça pousse
absolument quitter je sais que c'est une
question qui va peut-être arriver
éventuellement mais pourquoi choisir sur
versus maintenant une application qu'on
parlait par 12 mais c'est parce qu'elle
a le beau comment je peux dire la
thématique de sucre le concept et de pop
utilisées sont celles là où les examens
mais si l'action tout les trucs des
méditations ou des connaisseurs
desservent que tout ce qui est désordre
là sur les selles je fais un peu genre
contradictoire parce que monter la chose
qui me fait le plus de bien que c'est
juste à mal le goff qui est le seul à
côté des facs et on dirait c'est oui à
qui mettons la méditation vaud a aidé à
me déstresser mais mon selma stress fac
ça ne marche pas gagné en
mode avion même temps il ya des choses
peut pas utiliser
d une part la voir exactement maquillage
des spéciales la manche c'est comme le
peuvent
pas sortir de chez vous sentant seul il
faut que je fais marcher jusqu'au 2 mai
puis je laisse mon cell dans ma chance
ou un puis le ch genre s'est rendu
pesant par sinon tant d'artistes en tout
numérique sport il ya quelque chose qui
manque le type finalement marche je suis
dans ma taille parce que j'ai pas de
musique non plus quelque chose dans ma
tête même que je pense
oui mais c'est drôle parce que j'ai eu
une force des choses m mes mérites de
charles le trafic c'est perdre de temps
un mot des podcasts audio books tout je
les fais pitié on parle d'uli
d'hématomes économie si je l'écoutais
dans le show moment je dis c'est bon
mais après c'est le chemin dans une
foule de bons mais j'étais occupé
physiquement à créer des choses mais pas
de charlieu ses silences jeux primés en
tant que moi je me par la voix de
musique l'autre est arrivé chez nous
mais j'avais plein d'idées parce que
georges arrivé j'ai fait deux heures de
sharp le genre c'est un marcheur puis
par la voix au diable et nicole ici au
studio j'ai envoyé des messages vocaux
déjà plaide mme
montchamp j'ai des idées mais c'est
parce que je trouve que c'est vraiment
masques commencent à creuser là dedans
tout émergent tout c'est
faire la place à la place peu
d'équilibré vain de penser les mots-clés
exact fait que m le tu dis que ton
prochain et charles i sort demain demain
le 10 mai les cheveux quand savoir les
jeunes auront ça sera forcément une
prochaine collection la chaîne
collection aux tchèques sont avec nous
dans le fond la seule façon que les gens
peuvent succès sur ton compte personnel
je ne passe
ça s'appelle mot-à-mot
moto1 m au t1 non et moi je dis à temps
mais il ya trop haut à la fin parce
qu'il lit le nom était déjà réservée
jusqu'à frotter à m oh oh oh un
mot d'amour montrent un mot d'amour
[Musique]
simon
dans mabille août et puis sur sa vraie
joie est le pur design et design et vous
plaindre
si beaucoup
[Musique]
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin de ce pas que vous avez
apprécié la conversation ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup si vous voulez voir plus de
contenus plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passait sur p tu es
a non seulement on met tous les podcasts
en ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde paie turinois ce
que on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de
la conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur une page de recréer le lien
vers savoir dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin